perfect it's 3 20 now according to my
watch
so i think we can go ahead and get
started
uh so things look a little bit different
today and that's because
i have a guest speaker today cyrus hall
who's uh formerly of twitch and aws
and he's going to be giving a guest
lecture today about heterogeneous
distributed systems
and i'm very excited to welcome cyrus
and so
uh cyrus let's uh share your
presentation
and i think i'll drop myself off
if that's okay um and i'll i may pop
back on
uh if i have questions or if we have
stuff to discuss
um yeah actually um
yeah i'll pop off for now and then uh
maybe join in later
um but let's welcome cyrus take it away
cyrus
awesome um thank you very much so
thanks for the invitation uh thank you
to patrick
um for egging me on uh for a solid week
to do this
uh it's a pleasure to do it uh and thank
you
uh to everyone for coming um so today
i'm going to talk about
something i'm entitling for this talk
heterogeneous distributed
systems um and a little bit about me
before we get going
so i'm a former academic who
left academia after seeing my future
being 10 years of postdocking
but before then i got my master's at cu
boulder
working on sensor networks and i also
got a phd at the university of lugado
in switzerland on peer-to-peer networks
and a couple fun facts sort of related
to this presentation
my master's advisor was uh the
university of california santa cruz dean
of engineering alex wolff
um when he ran a lab at university
colorado
and fun fact too i actually climbed a
mountain in switzerland to fleshly land
so uh just sort of random
not really related facts over the last
nine years
uh i i spent time all of my time really
at twitch uh and then amazon web
services
uh leaving august of last year
uh during that period i architect built
and managed
significant portions of the video system
at twitch particularly
what was called the video replication
system which is the system
that if you're watching on twitch is uh
taking the video
from the origin of the video system and
making sure
it can make it to your computer smoothly
uh end of low latency uh more recently
i'm doing some advising and consulting
but also just taking
some time off so this talk this talk has
three parts
first we're going to define what is a
heterogeneous distributed system
then we're going to talk about how do
these systems develop
the way in which these systems develop
ie sort of get built up piece by piece
over time
is really important understanding why
they're so hard to deal with and they're
so hard to build and manage
and then we're going to go through a few
principles
of building onto and managing
a heterogeneous distributed system and
some rules of thumb
so if there's three things i'd like you
to take away from this talk
if you fall asleep after this slide
they're the following
heterogeneous systems are the natural
outcome
of complex products products
in this talk refer to features
on a website or a website itself or
maybe
a complex desktop app that has back ends
associated with it so
products are the application
products have diverse features they're
not just
rendering a static web page you can buy
things on them you can chat
on them you can configure them to
display content you can put in your
personal information
and this makes composing them inherently
difficult we're composing
multiple very different pieces of
functionality together
i also want to note that products that
are aimed at humans
that humans consume have more diverse
concerns
and sometimes entirely different
priorities
than distributed systems that are
focused on very narrow computational
concerns
so let's start with part one what is a
heterogeneous distributed system
and so we're going to talk about
something uh i've called first order
distributed systems
and how they compose into heterogeneous
distributive systems
and then we'll go through a brief web
scale
example so let's start with classic
distributed systems a distributed system
is multiple processes working together
towards some sort of common goal
they're distributed because they don't
share memory space
they're all operating in separate
processes maybe on the same machine
probably on different machines often
they use some
sort of a concept of time and ordering
you know i.e
vector clocks and they make acceptance
decisions
so can i accept this message does this
decision have consensus
uh sort of acceptance is often the
backbone of the conceptualization of a
distributed system
they tend to work well when service
semantics are focused
and when we're in a controlled
environment so we're doing
one thing typically with strong
guarantees
but we struggle to scale to wide area
networks
and so this led to more extreme if you
will distributed systems things like
peer-to-peer networks and sensor nets
the sorts of networks i worked on
back when i was an academic there's
still multiple processes working
together towards a common goal
a good example of this is the border
gateway protocol this is the
protocol that manages the routing table
of the internet and in general routing
and forwarding
algorithms are classic distributed
systems
they often are eventually consistent
where eventual in this case
actually means likely to never pass
there is no globally consistent view of
the internet routing table
doesn't exist why because routes take
time to propagate
and the rate at which routes change is
so
fast that bgp can never catch up
and that's okay for these more widely
distributed
uh distributed systems decisions in
these more extreme systems are often
made in a greedy manner and i mean that
in an algorithmic sense
they're greedy algorithms that are
designed to lead to eventual global
consistency
if changes to the system stop
of course changes to the system don't
stop so you never actually
reach that global consistency and that's
okay
but these are still related to your
class of distributed systems
fundamentally
the processes are all focused on a
common computational goal
and use a common algorithm we don't have
multiple systems
that are have different goals that are
using different algorithms talking to
each other these are systems with the
same goal
same algorithm so
i'm going to talk or refer to those kind
these kinds of systems we just talked
about as first
order systems they have a single purpose
there's no common memory space
and they all run the same algorithm and
when i say same algorithm of course
uh there are different components to an
algorithm
so if you're running paxis there may be
an a a leader right that leader is going
to perform
different actions than the other members
of the distributed system
but it's still the same algorithm it's
part of the definition of the algorithm
and there's lots of examples of these
first order systems
you have your classic consensus and
replication so paxos raft
google file system and s3 dynamodb
which i hear you just read about but
also some relational database systems
fall into this too if you have
relational database systems that have
replicas that are active
this is a distributed system networking
things like routing protocols bgp and
rip
overlay networks like tor which is an
onion router
and reliability protocols i would argue
that tcp
is a distributed system it's a bit of a
weird one
but it's multiple processes common goal
it uses effectively uses time stamps
and there's cooperation albeit implicit
between
multiple tcp connections in order to
manage
a segment of the network also p2p things
like distributed hash tables
gossip and bittorrent
so a heterogeneous distributed system is
composed
of more than one first order system
and importantly they may be distributed
systems
or they may be non-distributed systems
so i toyed with calling the second order
but i threw that
out because realistically these aren't
just made up of distributed systems
they're going to have a lot of
distributed components but then they're
also going to have
non-replicated databases sitting in them
they're going to have single points of
failure that are load balancers
so they're more complex than just a
collection of distributed systems and a
heterogeneous systems behavior is
determined by
the behavior of the first order
components but also the manner in which
they are
composed so by composing these things
together we're
changing the the
behavior that the system is going to
express
and i'll note that composition of
components
is primarily a human task that should
always be scary to us
because humans aren't very good at doing
things right and we'll see a lot of that
later in the talk
interactions between systems tend to
lead to complex failure modes
and so that is really the core
uh problem one is trying to solve when
working with heterogeneous distributed
systems so a quick example
uh to sort of try to just drive the
definitions home
here's your average web startup on the
very first day
founder has an idea um they want to
build a website for it
they download a web generation framework
they read the first two lines of
documentation they type in a name they
hit return it generates
ten thousand lines of code they hit run
and what they've done is they've
generated an
http api probably connected to a
database of some sort on the back end
typically something like
or mysql i'm going to use datastore just
to be generic
maybe this is a progressive web founder
and they're using like a nosql
you know uh database of some sort
so uh we have a distributed system right
a website doesn't just run a single
process
for its http server there's multiple
processes they're running the same code
they have the same purpose they're
basically a distributed system it's not
as fancy
or cool as pax is but it's a it's a
distributed system
and then we have a maybe distributed
system number two the data store and
together we have a heterogeneous system
so that's that's what we're talking
about
so it's important to talk about
how diverse systems can be
they tend to differ in a large subset of
properties
they have different purpose and goals
but they also have different frameworks
they're using different languages
they may not all be talking the same api
at twitch
in the video system we had systems that
talked bgp
that talked a google protobuf that
talked http
um that talked something called twerp
which was a twitch
special sas uh interface protocol
um so lots of diversity
service discovery frameworks might be
different some services
might be named of dns some services you
may need
need to call the service discovery
framework in order to get a reference to
the service
so composing these things together is
inherently hard
they may not exist in the same network
location
in a classic distributed system you're
running in the same data center
you're not running pax this wide area
in a heterogeneous system you have
possibly classic distributed systems
but they're going to be distributed in
different locations and now you have to
bind them together in a useful
way and you have configuration
even if you have multiple instances of
the same system
often they're configured differently and
that configuration leads to differences
in behavior so you can't even think of
them as the same
so each of these systems expresses
failure and error states and correctness
differently and that means hard to
compose
so even with our simple system that we
looked at where we really have
really three components we have a user
making requests
we have an http api and we have a data
store
it looks simple but it's already complex
the api likely does many different
things it's not just
doesn't just have one function it's
rendering an admin page and it's
rendering the front page and it's
rendering the
the channel page the consistency of the
data store doesn't actually guarantee
consistency of experience for the client
um the http api can get in the way
the client can get in the way there
could be in memory caching there could
be look aside caches
the data store has limited capacity we
have all these different api calls that
are making different uses of that
capacity
this is going to become a problem and
finally there's the client
there's uncontrolled code and that means
users can provide erroneous input to the
system
so with that i want to pause um
and i want to ask if there's any
questions i'm going to take a sip of
water
and uh scroll down to zulip
great so it looks like there was one
yeah it looks like there was one
question already sounds good
what are failure modes um sorry i should
have said at the beginning
you can absolutely ask questions at any
time i may just not see them until
i pause and take a look what are failure
modes
okay that's a great question i didn't
really define that did i
um so a failure mode is when
a system exhibits
some form of failure so for example
a system that's under high load could
have a failure mode
where some percentage of requests start
to return errors
or it could have a failure mode where it
just collapses
and explodes i.e
the process exits runs out of memory
runs out of sockets maybe
on the system so failure mode is a
generic way
of saying uh a system fails of some sort
of behavior
so the thing that struck me uh cyrus as
you were talking about uh
heterogeneous distributed systems and
introducing what that uh
that term means is that so
i'm i'm somebody who works on
verification and
so often we find
with verified software that you might
verify individual components
but bugs still come up at the interfaces
between components
and so so much of the time
somebody will be working with this
supposedly verified software
and still finding that there are bugs at
those
interfaces and that problem is
exacerbated the more
of these individual components you have
so of course that's the first thing that
i thought of
when i when i saw your slide and i think
there's a really great paper
from google called paxos made live which
this also made me think of which is
about their experience
deploying paxos as part of um
as part of the chubby lock service and
um you know paxos is one thing but
actually having it as a component as
part of this larger system is quite
another
and so you know in this class we study
paxos
right but then actually deploying it in
this context
and taking into account the complexity
of the surrounding system
makes everything harder and i'm really
excited that that is what you're talking
with us about today
yeah so i can actually give a quick
example of that from
uh from twitch where we ended up
deploying raft
um in a bunch of our data centers at one
point in order to store
uh data center um local information
and uh we were we were very excited this
information had
previously been stored in a central
database
that was not replicated was a single
point of failure
and had failed uh previously and so
the data was cached everywhere like the
the consistency or correctness of that
caching was questionable
um and so now we were going to have
definitive answers when we needed them
as to what the appropriate configuration
was
and the system that was going to manage
that information
was going to be highly reliable
via redundancy so this was exciting
and what we found was
one because we only had a single raft
instance and by instance i mean a set of
machines participating in the raft
protocol
and that multiple teams immediately
wanted to use the service
it was very difficult to control load on
raft
and so we started having too many people
try to do consistent reads
and then rafter get overloaded and get
slow and you start getting errors out of
it because like you get latency timeouts
and the other thing we discovered is
that we still needed caching it didn't
actually solve the caching problem
because just because something is
more reliable doesn't mean it's always
there and so you still
need to be ready for failure
and a lot of our problems
in deployment of that system ended up
being in making sure the caching
was correct not in using
basic raft so yeah
yeah absolutely i'm going to check
questions again really quick here
oh zach already knows what we're
actually talking about we're
actually talking about microservices
versus the monolith this is true
so part two um how do these systems
develop
um and the subtitle here and i'm going
to explain the monolith in just a second
the monolith decays and gives life to
many services from its ashes
reality keeps getting in the way
so let's go back to your average web
i just made that up it's not a quote i
don't know
thanks
[Laughter]
um so back to your average web startup
um just these these two uh
services again sorry wrong word systems
um this is classically called
the monolith and i don't
totally know who originated this um
but this is a term you're going to hear
in industry oh we have a monolithic
stack
what does that mean it means all of
their api calls are shoved
into a single
system that serves all sorts of
different purposes
and probably talks to a single data
store
this is where most people start um
but the reality is if we look inside
that http api
there's actually a bunch of different
components it's not just
an http api it's a web front-end api
it's probably an admin api maybe there's
a daily aggregation api that does
long-running aggregation tasks on the
data store of some sort
and these different apis have different
properties to them the front end
api it's largely online it has
very low latency requirements a user
makes a request
a user needs to get information back
daily aggregation tasks they're mostly
actually offline
high latency is okay they often take a
lot of
memory so running the daily aggregation
tasks
actually bloats the api in terms of
memory utilization
it may have a really heavy load on the
data back end
and then the admin is usually an awkward
mix of of these sorts of things
so we can recursively
um sort of apply what we we did with the
basic service
and start breaking the http api
into multiple services that better
reflect the different modalities of use
so here's one suggestion at a better
design
we could have a front end api an admin
api and an offlane
offline api all talking to the data
store
or throw a load balancer in front of it
at this point i'll talk
briefly about load balancers why do we
have load balancers
each one of these apis is really n
instances
of a process probably running on
different machines
hopefully and the client needs to have a
consistent
thing to address that consistent thing
is the load balancer
and then the load balancer also often
does failure detection
so if one of our instances in the api
fleet goes down
the load balancer's role is to detect
that usually just by some sort of ping
mechanism and to take it out of rotation
such that users don't get
errors our users talk the load balancer
get our offline scripts talk the load
balancer
so what problems do people see with this
and i'll i'll give you a minute to brain
dump in chat
i have some thoughts but first i want to
see what other folks in the class
might say well there was a question
actually about
what are some examples of daily
aggregation tasks
yeah so i can talk about that while
people are are thinking so
a daily aggregation task is something
that
usually gets run for business operations
so your business operations folks are
going to want to know things like
uh how many transact sales transactions
did we have today how many items were
purchased
how many people came to the site um how
long was their length of stay
you know these are important metrics for
the business they tell you if
things are getting going well are they
going poorly
do we need to make changes uh and in
small sites
these are often roll-up metrics where
there's
a trace of transactions that are made
and then there's some sort of
summary that goes through that trace it
sums it all up and makes some summary
statistics
um yeah so let's see so we're getting
some replies here
uh so julian says single centralized
data store and load balancer
yes absolutely timothy says what if the
load balancer is under
too much load yeah i i
this is sort of a nice subclass it's a
failure
mode of the centralized load balancer
let's say the uh offline scripts
are making a whole bunch of rapid fire
requests all at once on the load
balancer they may deny
uh requests from users the opposite
could be true as well maybe there's a
massive user spike suddenly and the
offline system is airing
cyrus if i could interrupt for one
second it looks like um
the slides are no longer showing up on
the stream
for some oh no okay oh now i see them on
stream again
so suddenly it disappeared and but now
it's now it's back
okay let me go back into full screen
again
oops not share i don't want to share um
are we good it looks good now
okay weird i don't know what happened
there
um no what is it it seems to have
disappeared again
oh it could be because i'm not in
that virtual yeah it's when i scroll
away
oh i'm sorry i'm in linux i'm trying to
be cool for you know virtual desktops
and stuff
and uh it's not working so let me move
let me move zulu up to the same screen
it might flash again for a second but
okay
should be back okay
um so uh let's see here so
someone had another one so zach said
what uh
what if uh the api goes down and the
load balancer has nowhere to route to
um that's a that's a good one so
one of the reasons we want to run
multiple instances
of each api on different machines is to
try to avoid the situation
where we have no instances of a
particular api that can still serve
requests
um of course that can still happen uh
you know and if that happens
yeah we're out of luck we we needed to
be running more
or maybe we weren't alerting and paying
attention to errors that were coming up
that can definitely also be a problem so
yeah let's go through
let's go through these let's start in
the back end so i think everyone
probably saw that the data store is a
single point of failure for all the apis
so this is really bad
if we lose the data store we lose all
our apis we don't actually have
resiliency
here and we still have this issue of
variable request patterns
where we're still applying very short
low latency requests from the front end
and
the offline api could still be locking
tables for long periods of time because
it's running
rollups at the end of the day we're
still vulnerable to spiky traffic
patterns
if there's suddenly a viral event this
happened at twitch
all the time there'd be a sudden viral
event that no one was expecting
and rather than having say 10 000 people
load video in a minute we'd have a
million people load video
in a minute that's a spiky traffic
pattern um
and so spiky traffic patterns you know
it's like it's gonna just take down the
front end api it's gonna take down the
data store
with it i also want to note that
resource management in this kind of
system is distributed
the front end api the other apis they're
each managing their request rate to the
data store
so if they're trying not to trample on
each other
they're gonna have to know about each
other's requests so they're gonna have
to know about each other's patterns
well now we've got strong coupling again
we want to avoid
that kind of hard coupling between
services maybe we could manage that in
the api
or sorry in the data store layer
and that can work we could have a
different user for each api
and then we could have a number of
outstanding requests
but fundamentally most data stores
can't rate limit based on the complexity
of the query
they can only rate limit based on the
number of requests
so a a bad request
that locks a table for example could
still come in and do damage
so that style of management tends to
fail as the number of services grow
in the front end most of you again you
saw that the load balancer is a single
point of failure
um but we also have the same sorts of
load issues with the load balancer as
well
i also want to bring up briefly privacy
and security concerns this is actually
worth
multiple lectures of time and i'm not
going to talk about it for the rest of
the lecture but i do just want to
mention it
really quickly a lot
of heterogeneous systems have caches all
over the place
sometimes load balancers cache but in
general one of the
the issues of heterogeneous systems is
because
data gets cached all over trying to
hedge against other systems failing
we're storing
user data all over the place and this
brings up privacy and security concerns
are there ways that a malicious actor
can get at that data
and it's best to separate these concerns
so in this case the load balancer if it
is caching things
could be caching the results of the
offline scripts
if those were to somehow become
available publicly that could be really
bad for the business
it could show that the business isn't
doing well it could expose
private user data about what they
purchased could have all sorts of things
in there that we don't want exposed
so this is one of these concerns that
while it exists in classical systems
privacy
i think is a much more upfront concern
than heterogeneous systems
so let's condense these concerns really
what we're talking about here are
availability and resiliency
where availability is the percentage of
a time that a system responds
it's a very simple measurement often
well
simple in theory uh often this is called
a number of nines so you'll probably
hear five nines
is 99.999 percent of a time
a system is available most
companies are pretty happy if they're
somewhere between
three and four nines honestly and a lot
of startups are happy if they're hitting
availability like is a bad place to be
um typically the more mature a product
the higher the desire for high
availability becomes
and then there's resilience it sounds
really similar and it is pretty close
resilience is the ability of a system to
remain
available so a low resilient
resilient system struggles a high
resilient system
has a lot of mechanisms to remain
available and resiliency is the product
of a lot of factors but there are some
key elements one is
how isolated from failure can i make a
system
can i isolate my availability from my
dependencies failing
can i isolate myself from my requesters
having issues either sending me too much
traffic
or having other failures redundancy and
ease of scalability a redundant system
that has multiple instances
or has backup copies is more likely to
remain available
and it also tends to mean it's easier to
scale
if i'm suddenly seeing quick growth on a
service
if i can't scale the service i'm going
to have availability issues
if i can scale the service i'm going to
probably avoid the availability issues
and then load management i'm going to
talk about this
more in the example section but being
available
may not mean a service is actually
properly functioning and this is
important
measures of availability often are no
more than
did i get a 200 http response a
success response effectively when i made
a generic request yes or no
it doesn't mean that the data contained
within that request
was correct maybe return junk
maybe at 200 and then return anything
this has concerning implications for
failure detection
it means that things like our load
balancers
that are using fairly simple mechanisms
may not detect a failure
this means failing hard can actually be
important
rather than failing soft right
completely failing being completely
inaccessible can be a better failure
state
if you cannot ensure proper functioning
under a partial failure
than being in a partial failure state
where you're returning bad
data so let's go to a second iteration
and we're getting close to a break i
know there's a 10-minute break coming up
so we're almost there
but let's quickly go through a second
iteration of the basic website
where we've separated out the apis we've
separated out our load balancers
we've even replicated the data store and
now the offline api
uses the replica rather than the main
data store
so it should have less ability to impact
us although
database replication is a bit weird and
that's not always true
[Music]
and even better if the replica if the
main data store fails
we could even just move into a read-only
mode with the replica for a period of
time until we can restore um
the primary data store so
this seems better right oh yeah or we
could just use dynamodb and not worry
about all this stuff i recommend that
but most most startups don't do that
um so this seems better
and what we're seeing is a recursive
service pattern
where if we look at our web front end
api we're also going to find feature one
and a bunch of different features there
that we might also want to split out
for example we have an api that's both
hosting
say a checkout api to purchase items
and is also hosting a page render api
one of those is more important than the
other from a product perspective
i want to make sure my website is up and
rendering pages
more than i actually care about the
ability to check out
doesn't matter if i can't render pages
it doesn't matter if i can check out or
not
um so we naturally
end up splitting individual features and
products
out as they grow in importance and as
new features
are added with maturity in companies
you eventually just start building new
features
as new services from the get-go
and really quick i've been using service
and system
a bit they both start with s and they
both sound really similar
so i want to take a second and i want to
just
try to try to separate them out here so
a system
is what we've been talking about as a
distributed system it's a set of
processes that implements a single
technical
function a service is a collection
of systems distributed or not that
implements a product
function so a chat service implements a
chat feature
and it consists of systems that
implement proxies api some sort of data
bus
between chat nodes
etc so applying that
to our second iteration we really have
three services here we have
a front end service an admin service and
an offline
service and those services consist of
the load balancer
the api and whatever data source we're
using directly
so with that it's break time
it's quiz time i guess before we do that
let me
check the questions
there is zulip um
oh no were we having issues on twitch as
well
only uh only minor issues with um with
the
uh um the uh
some of the slides we're not showing
momentarily but i think you got it
sorted out so
so yeah let's go through some questions
really quick and then we can do um
the quiz yeah
only 200 okay shouldn't other 200 status
codes also be acceptable
absolutely uh
that being said most
failure detection uh and i hope people
don't laugh too much at this but most
failure detection that is actually
performed
uh is as simple as calling a synthetic
http endpoint often entitled something
like
alive or okay
that doesn't return any data and
performs no operations and simply just
echoes 200.
that is i'm not going to call it the
gold standard because it's not
but it is the the normal behavior of
most uh failure detection systems
um ike says it might be useful to
distinguish between hardware
and software failures i
totally agree um
[Music]
i wasn't gonna dig into that to this
talk
uh but there's there's a lot of nuance
yeah there's uh there's a lot of nuance
there
um hardware failures
well there's all different types right i
mean that's part of why hardware failure
is so hard to talk about
there's your easy hardware failure which
is your power supply dies
and the machine turns off that's an
awesome sort of failure because
it's it's really definitive right it's
like
it's down and nothing responds but then
you have really annoying hardware
failures like
one of your memory dim dies but
linux is awesome and it just keeps
running mostly except not entirely and
there's some really weird memory
corruption errors
or your hard drive or ssd dies
um and you're actually uh or
it doesn't die die but like partially
dies and you start getting file system
corruption
and it's creeping and you don't really
notice it for two months and it's your
database machine
those kind of errors are really
unfortunate uh
and it's why you create backups for
things like data stores
huh yeah
yeah it's better to be resilient to
failure than to try to special case
failure
uh and that's a fine that's like a
really
delicate line and i guess a difficult
statement to parse
um but be prepared to recover from
failure
rather than trying to manage it if that
makes sense so if you discover your
database as corrupted
that's okay because you have a backup
that's recent
or you were using
yeah i i completely agree i think a lot
of the hardware
the slowly bubbling hardware failures
um don't tend to become a concern
of maybe they should um
a system well of
distributed system engineers they tend
to be more of a concern
of system operators and system engineers
who
are monitoring for failure as well as
they can
and who are advising the distributed
systems engineers
on how to make sure
they are prepared for data corruption
and other
other sorts of phenomenon so i think if
you're prepared for data corruption
then where that data corruption comes
from is a little less important
right if it's coming from software
injecting bad data if it's coming from
ecc errors injecting bad data
but yeah it's a difficult question i i
think you have to talk specifics when it
comes to hardware
um are there common methods of soft
failure detection regarding the actual
data returned
not that i'm aware of um there could be
i'm not aware of them i haven't seen
them used uh
in general there are statistical
failure detection methods that
might look at very specific types of
return values and check them against a
known good distribution
but that has limited applicability
and can be difficult to really um
set up correctly so an example of that
would be let's say
i want to monitor if an http endpoint
that renders a particular page is
returning good data
i could monitor the length of the return
data
so if i have a bunch of good returns
and i i look at that statistical
distribution
i can then use that as a model for what
good is and apply that
to future returns
that works great of course unless the
page changes
and often the binding
between the people who are building the
distributed system and the people who
are
designing the look and feel of the web
page and what components are on it
uh maybe they switch frameworks and it
just like bloats the html or they really
reduce it because they're working on
latency
um having that communication
ahead of time and then like rebuilding
that model so it doesn't alert and
suddenly detect an error when there
isn't one
that gets really complex and hard that's
a really good point
and yeah i think your your point about
how
if you have a false positive that can
get really tiresome really fast
especially if somebody is getting paged
as a result of that and then you get
into problems with
um those pages being ignored right
if they alert too often when there's not
actually a problem
so then you have a boy who cried wolf's
situation so you
you so there's a there's a technical
term for that
uh slipping my mind right now um i think
it's called
alert fatigue um so um
and it's a real uh serious uh
hci issue in the design of these systems
so it's something that you have to watch
out for
yeah having been on call for years and
years and years at twitch i can attest
that alert fatigue is very real and
uh
[Applause]
if he's on the line let's hear it um
yeah he still has alert fatigue i mean
patrick
will remember conversations we had on
the team about
which alerts to turn off and i
distinctly remember patrick saying this
is a useless alert
it alerts too much i hate it i want this
alert
to die he didn't probably use that word
but and i probably said something like
yes but occasionally it's right
which is the wrong response right like
that's
i don't remember i just i i
i just remember having these
conversations with you and the rest of
the team
right around some of our noisier
uh alerts so to give a clear example
uh the the team that uh i managed that
patrick was on
was responsible for all of our edge
servers across the world
we managed all the http servers all the
caching
all the intermediary caches all the
configuration
and all the the services that ran a side
cars through those those http servers
and we had likeness alerts that
did the thing a little bit better than
the
the generic response they they
got a random manifest for a stream on
twitch and they tried to play it back
sometimes streams just have weird
difficulties
where the inbound stream has errors
and the transcoder struggles to
transcode that stream
into multiple renditions or even to
segment that stream
into useful video segments
and when that happens the transcoder had
errors
where it would output segment names that
didn't actually exist
and so then the playback check would
alert saying oh
i am failing to get data on this machine
alert alert the replication something in
replication is broken on this box
that's not useful it's not actually a
replication systems problem it's
actually the transcoder's problem
so building smart
domain aware alerts is really hard
because you don't actually know the full
domain it's not all your domain you
can't know everything at the point where
you're
you're doing the alert yeah
yeah so kyle asks uh when in this
process of scaling your architecture
do you care about software failure
detection correctness of a system
under partial network failure oh that's
a
really interesting question and i i
think it's very dependent
on the on the heterogeneous system that
you're talking about
a lot of systems exist in
a single say cloud region so
if you're on aws a lot of systems exist
entirely within us west too
network partitions within that
environment
are significantly lower probability
than if you're running heterogeneous
system across multiple data centers
um multiple geographic locations i
should say because us west 2 is multiple
data centers
although you as a user don't really see
that
in the case of twitch uh partial network
failures were a big deal
to us we could easily end up in
situations where we would
lose a route to a particular dc
but only from a particular perspective
in the network so
for example we had an
actual outage last year
beginning of the year where
services in us west 2 suddenly were
unable to talk
to a bare metal data center sitting
out on the east coast and so
all of the liveness alerts went off they
said oh everything's dead everything's
down a big alert emergency emergency
emergency
and yet the system seemed to be working
uh like streams were some streams were
viewable
like components of the system seemed to
be up uh
and it was a it was a partial network
partition
effectively um the system was fairly
resilient to it
not entirely out of luck but partly
because we had taken steps
to avoid particular types of network
failures for example
even though dns isn't part of the
network
a lot of engineers think of it like it's
part of the network so
we we cache dns results
i i i uh
you know shudder when i say that because
i a lot of people say that's horrible
never ever do that but it
saved us so many times when dns crashed
it's incredible
this turned out to be i have to remember
this this turned out to be a link
failure
that was misdiagnosed initially
as a network partition uh their actual
us west 2 could actually talk
to the data center we thought was
disconnected and i'm not remembering the
specifics well enough it was a very
i was actually uh incident response
manager for this
and it was complex enough that
no one caught it day of we actually
recovered the situation without fully
understanding
the air took us a couple days to really
understand what had happened
um i think it involved a border router
someone running code on the border
router some weird optical states like
i mean a twitch just went all the way
down to optics because we managed the
optical network
that the video was i mean twitch still
run manages the optical network that the
video runs on
and that's really important for latency
it's really important for quality of
service
and having video play smoothly
but border routers are a whole beast in
and of themselves
in that they're really not built for
automation
and the way automation happens is people
write expect scripts that log in
and then do things or worse they cut and
paste
scripts from text files into them
and uh yeah that can lead to that can
lead to problems
so all right so let's let's take the
break
and let's let's do the quiz yeah that
sounds good so i'll put our quiz up
and uh let's take a 10 minute break
and uh yeah so let's see now it's it's 4
12.
so let's return at 4 22
and i'm going to take uh
us off the stream for now cyrus but we
can continue
chit chatting uh on zoom for 10 minutes
and then
resume on the stream after that awesome
sounds good
all right welcome back uh i'm gonna
stop sharing this and cyrus you can
bring back your
presentation it should be back
yep it's back great perfect um
and uh can we talk about quiz results
really quick lindsay
absolutely yeah so let's see we got
a hair over 70 responses to the quiz
okay yeah so so it looks so the right
answer here was the
multiple product features are stuffed
into one api right
that is correct um yeah so so it looks
like about
that's what about 60 of the responses
said
um and then yeah then like 35
said too many distinct apis but that i
mean that's
maybe kind of like half what you were
talking about as well i would say
yeah and then there was a small number
of responses thought it was uh that when
an api can't decide what to do
which is the funny that is that is the
truth right so
yeah four people said that it looks like
yeah so um first of all i want to make
clear this isn't a real term
uh this is a term i made up i don't
recommend using it
um but in general what i was describing
was the the fact that you have uh
sort of these distinct subsets of apis
within a monolith
uh that do very different things um
but uh the second the second most
popular response
is interesting because one of the
problems
with a what's often called a
microservice architecture where
every little individual business
features its own
service inside of systems is that
you do just get a heck of a lot of
services and systems
and that can in itself be difficult to
manage
so welcome back uh everyone i i want to
go back to iteration two
um and i unfortunately need to tell you
this is not actually how iteration two
ever
looks um this is like definitely not
perfect but
uh this is way too clean for iteration
two on a site
uh what actually happens is all this
engineering is happening
hopefully during a hyper growth phase
because the company's doing
really well and you're having
operational and downtime events
probably every day they're not fifty
percent of the site's time but they're
fifty percent of engineering's time
trying to figure out why they're
happening and what to do about them
and what to do about them is definitely
not to fundamentally fix them
because product changes are coming every
day and
sales is selling features that don't
even exist yet
so you know they're out making million
dollar contracts for a feature you need
to implement in the next two months
so the loin loan voices that are sitting
in the corner
that are saying you know guys we should
really standardize
all of this and stop doing a billion
different things
are kindly told to shut up basically uh
not on those words but
like maybe sometimes in those words
most services are still adopting their
own unique resiliency and failure
strategies at this point
and the other thing to just sort of have
it as context is
engineers in this kind of environment
burn out
they leave knowledge gaps develop
services that used to have owners don't
have owners anymore
the new adopted owners don't really
understand how they work they may not
understand the resiliency
mechanisms they may not understand the
failure strategies
so here's a more realistic second
iteration
um the offline api unfortunately took
down the front end at some point so it's
been removed off the load balancer and
now scripts just call the offline api
directly
the load balancer is still used for both
the front end and the admin api
the data store's slowing down so someone
threw in a right back cache
this is typically something that looks
like a memcache or redis
where results or partial result results
from the data store
are stored in the cache and before
making a request the data store the
front-end api first
checks if the write-back cache has a
previous result for the same query
but you know the write-back cache also
is limited so someone also threw in an
in-memory cache
in the api which is basically just a
smaller version of the right back cache
so what are the problems we've
introduced
here and i'll i'll pause again briefly
and see if folks
have spotted some interesting new
problems we we certainly still have the
single points of failure and the load
balancer
and the data store but we also now have
new problems we didn't have before
so
well this caching here is looking a
little bit suspicious
i agree um caching is super sus
to use to use modern lingo
um your keyboard broke
so alex says greater security risks with
the offline scripts
now being able to directly access the
offline api
zack says caching sus
caching is the imposter oh boy yeah i
didn't mean to quite bring up that but
um
yes often caching is the imposter in
that the data in the cache
uh is actually no longer good
and so you have
um okay we have the spots um
yes there's the server failure thing but
we have consistency issues here right
like is the end memory cache consistent
of the right back cache
what about the data store what about the
right back cache in the data store like
oh my lord we have consistency issues
all over the place
this isn't to say that caching is bad
it's not
it's an essential part of highly
available systems there's no way to get
around using caches and highly available
systems
however they're very difficult to get
right
and they almost always cause issues when
they're first
introduced due to consistency problems
yeah i mean as soon as you're doing
caching doing replication
and then you have all of the bad things
that come with replication but you're
doing it by hand
right so rather than taking
say a database as the data store and
having a bunch of replicas of it say
read replicas
and then differentiating whether you're
using a read replica
if you're doing something that's read or
if you're going to the primary data
store if you're doing it right
all of which turns out to actually be
quite complex to set up and manage
in the real world and also typically
requires a dba
which i note are really short supply in
the labor market
since you don't have that dba people
throw caches at the problem instead
and throw engineers uh
who may not have studied consistency or
think of consistency
and yeah you end up with consistency
problems
yeah let's i'll double check here what
kind of cache is that
um so in general the right back cache
is going to be uh a
um
a system of some sort usually a memcache
or a redis
it can be something like dynamo although
that's less common for a cache
and so these are key value stores in
general
they also can support
uh some item some non-item potent
operations and that can be a trap that
people fall into
the in-memory cache is likely just
a set of data structures within the web
server
that are shared between threads
within a particular instance that's the
other thing to mention about the
in-memory cache
is that different versions of the
front-end process are going to have
incoherent
in-memory caches there isn't a
in-memory cache protocol synchronizing
across the different processes here
they're each
going to be based on the particular
requests and timings of those requests
that the front-end api
received there are situations in which
this is perfectly okay
but then there's also a lot of
situations in which this causes
really interesting effects if a client
makes multiple requests in a row and
hits different front-end api servers
there's another possible issue that
occurs to me here and
i i can't decide if this is worse in
this picture or if it was worse in the
first iteration
so um before we had the offline scripts
talking to the load balancer
and now we don't yeah and at first this
seems kind of simpler
that they wouldn't talk to the load
balancer but on the other hand
if they're not talking to the load
balancer then the load balancer
won't have the opportunity to stop the
offline scripts from taking up too much
traffic to the data store so those
offline scripts you know
if they're doing something that's not
particularly essential and you have a
lot of client requests to serve then
maybe you should
you know turn them off right uh and
you know you can always run that report
tomorrow or whatever but in this design
there's not any
it doesn't look as though there would
necessarily be a way to handle that
yep and it also pushes failure detection
to the scripts
because now if one of the offline api
machines dies
um that that you know that binding
is at the level of the script itself
that that name like what name am i
talking to
rather than just talking to the load
balancer which is probably has a dns
name in front of it uh just as a note
to folks the reason this is actually
very close to what happened
at twitch with our monolith this was
basically iteration to what's on the
screen right here
and the reason that there wasn't a
second load balancer that load balancer
cost 400 000
it was a piece of hardware right no one
had 400 000 to buy a second piece of
hardware just for some offline scripts
so um so
really this is as much business as
engineering
right these systems are in part the
result of
business decisions and as engineers it's
important that we make
our best estimates of risk and impact
known to the business when they're
asking us to modify
or add things to a system but we have to
also accept that there needs to be a
healthy balance between the engineering
concerns
the product concerns and the business
needs
this is okay it feels not okay
i think when you're a new engineer in
this space this feels
like i'm not being allowed to do the
right thing that's how it can
how it can feel but uh it's not
the right thing isn't being done it's
not the right thing for the business is
being done
and that isn't always the best thing
from an engineering perspective
so heterogeneous system engineering is
partly about finding a sense of
zen about these conflicts
of interest and the balance that exists
between them and i'll just say
i'm still working on it i think this is
a lifelong process for anyone in this
space
but it's important to not
freak out the first time you experience
this conflict
it's natural and it's healthy and it's
okay
so where did this leaf twitch when i
joined in 2012
the video system was basically a
monolith with five core
systems running in a single data center
and that monolith
actually originated in 2009 if i
remember correctly
by 2020 it was a microservice
architecture of
over 120 services but each one of those
services
was multiple systems usually two to four
systems
that's going to be a load balancer at
this point software load balancing
hardware stuff is horrible don't use it
an api
one or more data stores and possibly
other components
so realistically um there were
probably 300 systems
running but many of them running in
multiple regions
with different configurations because
they were they were replicated across
multiple cloud regions and multiple bare
metal regions
the original monolith finally died in
april of this year so
it effectively survived uh 12 years
that's that's an incredible amount of
time that's normal monoliths
take a long time to die they become so
central to everything
that unwinding the dependencies is just
a huge process
and adopting common patterns to things
like failure detection
service frameworks load balancing
deployment
we're key to success but the reality is
that it's not there yet there's still a
lack of standards and that still causes
problems
adopting a cloud environment like aws or
azure
can help the services that already exist
within that environment such as the load
balancers
are built to work together
and they come with a particular
philosophy and each cloud service has a
different philosophy
but you're sort of forced to adopt that
philosophy
and that helps standardize at least even
if you don't like the philosophy
at least you're doing the same thing
over and over again
that helps makes things more predictable
so part three
some ideals and a few rules of thumb
and this is the motivational speaker
part of the talk so accept failure don't
try again
embrace air if possible
be stateless i think that's a pun on on
tasteless but
uh yeah of course yes uh yeah
and isolate isolate isolate
um so how one actually deals
with i'll use the word chaos
of heterogeneous systems uh there are so
many things to talk about there's not
enough time
but uh i want to cover i want to cover
things at a high
level really quickly and then dig into
one particular point
of concern so first of all
every system and service should ideally
and i've said this a lot in this talk
address a single concern this is
so important if a system or service gets
built that addresses multiple concerns
uh inevitably it's going to end up with
more dependencies both inbound and
outbound and that means it's going to be
all the harder to separate those
concerns
later it means the failure modes are
going to be all the more complex
when you fail you're going to affect
more things it's harder to have
isolation between concerns
and this really goes together with the
second item which is
you want to be loosely coupled as much
as possible
if you address many concerns really hard
to be loosely coupled
be easy to maintain this is more than
just code maintainability
this means have the semantics of the
system be easy to test
if i can't test the system still works
the same today
as it did yesterday i don't know if
other dependencies of the system
are going to reject those changes or not
i don't know if they're going to be okay
with them
this means systems have to be easy to
test this is almost always missing
be independently and repeatably
deployable
i'll take two minutes on this one what
does it mean to be
independently deployable it means
as a system i can deploy
changes only to that system
i do not have any dependencies on
deploying changes to
other systems that i depend on this is
really important
to make deploys easy and the second
thing repeatable which we'll get to
if i have to deploy to multiple systems
to make a change to the one that i'm
really targeting i have much more
complex rollout processes now
and deployment is one of those points in
a system's life cycle
where failure tends to happen i deploy
new code
that code doesn't work i deploy code to
a different set of machines and then i
try switching over to it
and they're not performing as well maybe
they have
they take more time per request right
all sorts of things can happen here
so if we can reduce the complexity we
reduce failure
and things should be repeatably
deployable this means that if i deploy
the same code
each time i deploy it the exact same
thing should happen
if i deploy the same code and i get a
different result
and this by the way is quite common
early in deploy systems
because configuration and deploy are
intricately linked together
it can be very hard to know if after
deploy i'm in a good state
so there was a period of time at twitch
where our main monolith
the standard operating procedure was to
deploy twice
because by deploying twice you are more
likely to get a good deploy the second
time
and this is because of the the
interaction between how
services were configured in the
deployment system
finally have clear documentation of a
system or services behavior and
semantics
that way when you move on either to a
different system
to a different part of the company to a
new job entirely
to retire in the mountains surrounded by
nature and birds
everyone who remains has some idea of
how
this artifact actually works so let's
zoom in on the second one here on loose
coupling and talk about
a couple rules of thumb patrick knew
this was going to be in here
i love this one retries are dangerous
um try not to do them why are retries
dangerous
now i want to just preface this is
within the context of heterogeneous
systems so we're not talking about
um a distributed system uh
you know a first order distributed
system that has a very
particular purpose we're talking about a
heterogeneous collection of systems here
so what happens the the gray arrows are
our request path here
so the api oh and the um sorry i took
out the load balancers i just
drew them as queues basically a load
balancer can be thought of as a queue of
requests
um if there's enough capacity the queue
might be empty
but if there's not enough capacity in
the back end requests start to back up
in the queue so the api makes a request
to the load balancer
and at that point the api doesn't really
know what happens maybe the load
balancer forwarded it
hopefully maybe the data store responded
maybe it didn't but what we do know is
we get an error back
so there's red dashed arrow we're
getting an error response
so the first thing a lot of engineers do
is they retry
and they get an error and they retry
again so
what's what's happening as we do this we
don't know
we could just be banging our head
against the load balancer
which might be in a bad configuration
maybe it's overloaded maybe the queue is
full
or we could be putting more load on the
data store
if the data store isn't responding
because it's overloaded putting more
load on it
is not going to resolve that problem if
the data store
is close to failure and we put more load
on the data store the data store
will fail and now we're really in
trouble right
so i think the first thing to understand
of retries in a heterogeneous system
is from our vantage point we don't
actually know what those retries are
going to do necessarily
and if we're retrying after an error
they're likely going to make
a bad situation worse let's also talk
about item potency for a second
so now rather than just datastore that
that that database looking thing now
says memcache
memcache is a particular key value store
and it conveniently has this operator
called
inker and inker does exactly what you'd
expect it
increments the value of a named variable
within memcache
so in this case let's say we have a
variable x and it equals zero
and then someone issues an api request
and that request gets translated
into a memcache command inker x1
so this means increment the value of x
by one
awesome we issue the command
to the load balancer and we get an error
so what has happened well we don't
really know
but you know heck let's oh okay
for sake of argument let's say what
happened is that memcache
incremented the value returned something
to the load balancer but something went
wrong
in that interface and we get an error
back
well let's retry anchor x1
air anchor x1 air so now we've
incremented the value to three
we intended the value to be one um
so like our conceptualization
of what the value is supposed to be what
it actually is is completely
inconsistent at this point
we've put more load on memcache we
haven't diagnosed the problem
and we certainly haven't done what the
request the api was
telling us to do let's talk about
patrick's credit card example this is a
example that patrick posed to me about a
month ago
a system takes an order a credit card
number and generates an order record
the requesting client is the web friend
that's going to display the result to
the user once the the credit card is
charged
upon trying the third party credit
processor the system receives an error
message
should we retry let's take a 30 second
um pull and chat
uh great question
let's see the question is do i reveal
patrick's answer
i
rather than uh bothering to try to do a
zoom poll
especially since a lot of people aren't
on zoom
yeah let's just let's just see what um
what folks say
uh on zulip so
so we got a no we've got to know raphael
i'll give it 15 more seconds well you
did just say that retries are evil
i did this is true
kyle says
um
something something everything is a
trade-off that's true
[Music]
if it's base house so no
okay so should we retry um oh the actual
answer is depends
uh trick question uh but probably no
yeah probably no if unless the credit
card processor
you know has really convinced us
that we will never receive an error uh
and the charge uh the card was charged
if they can't convince us of that no
heck no we should not retry
we really don't want to double charge
the customer we'd much rather
we just give them an error and say hey
try again right didn't go through
yeah so
next try to make stateless requests and
this is sort of what we just covered if
the item potency here right
uh it's hard not to retry if a
transaction is completed in multiple
parts we may have
partially completed something we may be
in a state that we don't want to just
leave there
or that would leave some sort of state
crumbs
try not to do this try not to make
non-item-potent
requests so for the memcache example
do store the new value don't increment
the value
now what does this imply it implies we
have to
get the value first so we have to do a
get request
get the value increment it in the
process and then do a store
this is more costly but that cost is
worth it from a semantics standpoint and
a consistency standpoint
if you need transactional semantics if
you can't avoid them
use a proven service that provides them
for you
don't try to create them in your own
services
propagate errors early what does this
mean
it means if i get an error rather than
retrying
just return it to the requester and in
fact
return it all the way up the stack to
the very original requester
make the air their problem why their
problem
well the error lets us know the system
is struggling right
might be close to failure could be
something wrong
but the request may not even be
important anymore the user may have
loaded the page they may not care about
our particular service
the request might not be timely anymore
maybe
if we answered it now it just doesn't
matter anyway
let the original requester figure out if
they care
a lot of product managers don't like
this but it's something to have a long
and multiple discussions of your product
managers about
and then finally and i know i'm rushing
because i know we're low on time
um early error return goes even better
of active load control
and there's multiple versions of this
i'm going to talk about one
where not only do we have a load
balancer
but our local process instance also has
a request
queue an outbound request queue and as
requests come
in this queue might start to fill up
this is indicating that the data store
is probably getting busy
because requests are taking more time if
a request comes in
and that queue is full don't even try to
process it
return an air immediately
that feels bad because maybe if we cued
it we'd get to it maybe it would all
work like shouldn't we try
but the problem of trying here is we're
just adding
more pressure more load to the systems
that we depend on
we'd rather back off hopefully let them
recover
the queue starts to go down and then we
can put another request
in if most systems do this
it's unlikely the service is ever going
to collapse
we might have some errors there might be
some page error loads maybe some
transactions don't complete but we're
available
generally to our users retries can be a
necessary evil
if you have to do them use back off
however understand that if you're doing
back off this
implies a rapid buildup of request state
in your system
that has memory implications i've seen
systems
out of memory because they were using
retries
there's a major user rush
their back end goes down
they're retrying they run out of memory
i'm just going to skip that one because
we're out of time i believe
and go to the conclusion uh complex
business processes and life cycles
lead to these really complex
heterogeneous systems
holding back the business isn't the
right trade-off
instead we need to use tools like
isolation and loose coupling and a lot
of other techniques
to help lower risk and impact when
failure does occur
and failure will occur and that's okay
that's expected if your business leaders
are telling you
don't make things better and then they
get really upset when there's failure
that's a discussion that the vp of
engineering or cto needs to have of the
business leader
so engineering is as much a social
process as it is a heads-down process
and designing code
and with that uh thank you very much
there's my email if you want to email me
if you're interested in interns
in this space internships in the space
it's unfortunately too late for the
summer but in the future
feel free to email and i can certainly
reach out and connect you with people
within uh twitch and aws
all right cyrus thanks so much for this
wonderful talk it really brought
together
a lot of the ideas that we've been
talking about all quarter
in a sometimes much much more abstract
context and it made them very concrete
and visceral
so thank you let me also point out that
we have a lot of graduating students so
some of them are going to be looking for
not just
uh not just internships but full-time
positions
so uh thank you very much for yeah thank
you for volunteering
uh to to talk to folks about that and i
would urge
all of you to take cyrus up on the offer
yeah you have my email uh i conveniently
have a fair amount of time right now
so feel free to email me
uh you know whether it's about
opportunities
uh or if it's just if you have more
questions uh about
the lecture be happy to talk
what was that slide that we skipped over
was that uh
that was oh that's those are my backup
slides um
limiting yeah okay yeah so
this is a great one um
yeah so every service or system has
some sort of sustainable load peak right
like
if you think about a a specific
configuration of a system
you have x number of instances
of the service running and you have a
particular mixture of requests that are
flowing into that service
those mixtures tend to be fairly
standard
with those two pieces of information you
can calculate your peak sustainable
load before you start to see service
degree degradation
um awesome do that
and then have a rate limiter that only
allows x percent of that peak
sustainable load into production at any
given time
you know something like 95 98 of that
peak sustainable load
this is a way that doesn't involve the
actual
uh handling process having to think
about its state
to easily make sure that a fleet of api
servers
is going to remain up during a load
spike that would overwhelm peak
sustainable load right you just
let your rate limiter which is usually
your load balancer
deal with it for you and just shed that
load early
shedding load is okay right those users
will hit reload
so what you're really doing is you're
not getting rid of the load you're
smoothing it out at a sustainable
maximum peak
where if you tried to take that load
your performance would start to degrade
very rapidly that that
you know degradation becomes non-linear
almost immediately and then you collapse
and
now no one's on the website so you'd
rather
reject cap off smooth
and and stay available and rate limiting
is a great way to do that um
yeah so these two techniques go together
really well
i'd recommend both because they sort of
solve different problems um
this you know active load control on
your dependencies
is really looking at is your dependency
healthy rate limiting for your service
is really trying to make sure your
service is healthy so they're addressing
two different things in my mind
they are related in that if you're
taking on too much load
your dependency might be taking on too
much load but they're best in
combination with each other
all right well we're unfortunately out
of time so in an effort to
rate limit the flow of information into
everyone's brains
i think we're going to end the broadcast
here but thanks
and uh so i'll see you thursday